the viennese doctor and psychoanalyst
sigmund freud hypnotized is a
patient interpreted her dreams and
discovered the dimension of the
unconscious every human being is so happy has
hidden desires longings and drives
serve subliminally
influence lust and sexuality
from childhood on also play a major role
the infant lives for  example still completely
according to the pleasure principle takes everything
into his mouth with lust screams when he
desires something and laughs when he is doing well
but he soon has to learn that he has to obey the
parents, the teachers and society
with their rules the
infantile pleasure principle is so
happy  brutally detached from the principle of reality
every citizen of the world has this
experience and the development of our
sexuality and our
relationships sometimes leads to insults and
trauma. freud was a doctor he
was a doctor and practiced a
revolutionary treatment
method, psychoanalysis, he was the first to discover it
that mental illnesses or
even people’s attitude towards life in general
often stems from experiences that can
not be changed afterwards
but
can be
emotionally re-evaluated within the framework of
therapy  60 minutes,
his revolutionary and innovative view
of man is
explained step by step using many examples and with over 40 quotes
because all the important building blocks of
his theory from the oral phase, the
oedipus complex, the drive, conflict,
sublimation, repression,
resistance, the formation of symptoms,
transference to the  therapy builds
on each other in
the second part of the book the question
is asked what is the use, we are happy
about discovery today and it is amazing
how important and helpful
knowledge can be for our personal way of
life if you use
it correctly